So, where do you where do you get this
from that that it was somebody that
threw Jesus under the bus that was
crucified in this place? Where do you
get that from? The Quran don't say that.
I heard it from somewhere.
It's God. It's God. It's
God. It's God.
There's like hundreds of different
Bibles. So, which one's the right one?
Who made the Bible? You start learning
that the Bible came
It was made like years after prophet
Jesus. Who told you this? Just Google
it, bro. Dude, the council come out like
later on, you know? Nobody has uh like
carbon dated or original sources.
Matthew and John, they were literally
disciples of Jesus and they wrote down
what he taught. They're not the the
disciples written in the Bible. They're
not the same people of that time. You
know what I mean? How do you know that?
Cuz there's no proof, bro. Tell me you
can show me like Mark said this. Like
look. Okay. For example, you have in in
Matthew's gospel. Well, who wrote this
book? Matthew. I'm going to show you
this particular book. Where did this
particular book come from? You know what
I mean? This this whole collection. The
whole collection. Where did it come
from? Well, these are different authors.
The the Bible is a is a bunch of
different authors. Like, where did this
entire book come from? I'm I'm telling
you. So, so what the what the Bible is,
it's a collection of writings from
different prophets and apostles. That's
the issue. How's that an issue if if it
all lines up? It
doesn't. You know what I mean? So, tell
me what what do you mean like give me
give me some details. What do you say?
So, who has the authority to write this
book? The prophets and the apostles of
Jesus. Okay. But who printed this book?
Like who who printed it? Um, well, I
mean, some businesses, I guess. At
first, they didn't have they What do you
mean? Who printed this? Like this is a
printed Quran. Does that mean does that
mean that the Quran is false? Now the
thing about the Quran though is that you
will find it perfect. In what way? Every
every Arabic Quran you won't find a
contradiction within them. But we do,
dude. No, you don't. Bro, have you heard
of Huffs? Like I'm talking about the
Arabic ones. I know. I know. Look, look.
We have We have Arabic. This is This is
called a a Huffs Quran. This is called a
worsh. Okay. These are two different
Arabic Quran.
pull up a contradiction between both of
these. They were different themselves.
Okay. So, you have Yeah. Yeah. I got
you. So, you have
um let's go
to chapter
number. Goodness. Forgive me on my Arab.
Is this horse? Okay. Horse.
Anthony. Anthony, I need your
help. What? Can you go to 3146? 3146 or
uh the katal jungle. Who are we? You
guys were Muslims, bro.
You look like you look like I look like
they call me
Abdulatif. Abdullahif is my name.
Okay, look. So,
um Okay, here here it is. So, in this
word, this is the word. It's catalog.
Okay. Okay, which means many of it says
many of prophets fought with hell and
did not lose heart. Right. This is the
worsh. That's a different word here.
It's it's is very similar but the
diritical marks changed the word. This
is coutila instead of katala. This means
many prophets were killed and they did
not lose heart. So this shows that this
says that they were killed. This one
says that they fought. They didn't die
and fought right people dying when they
fight not all the time and and and in
the context here like this is what
Islamic scholars like uh Alabar he says
this one would be incor incorrect that
says that they were killed because right
after it it says that they did not lose
heart so you can you can only not lose
heart if you're alive to not lose heart
all right you know so that's that's what
some of them say this is a small example
but there's others you know what I'm
saying and this is Arabic this isn't
English you know what I'm
So would you say that this like means
that the Quran is untrustworthy now? No.
So then that's not your problem then if
if you have the if you have a Bible that
has you know English versions that are
that are slightly different. It's not a
big problem then. Not really bro. You
got like way different problems though.
You know what I mean? Like like what?
Cuz you're talking about you have a
Christian and you have a Catholic. So
you would they have the same but they
have the same. Hey bro, you're not a
real Christian. No.
Do this. That's a culture. All right,
let's go with this. You know what I'm
saying? Cuz you're right. There are some
Catholics and then there's like some
Protestants that they have their own
Bible, you know. No, no, no. Yeah, they
do. All right. Let's let's let's put
this in perspective. We got to be
consistent. Okay. I'm acknowledging what
you're saying. There are differences.
You have Catholics, Orthodox,
Protestants, different denominations
within Christianity. You have this in
Islam, too. You have Sunnis and Shia.
Sunnis and Shia. They talk through each
other. There's a a clear description
where it's like if you're a Muslim in
the Quran, it says you read the Quran,
you practice the the teachings of the
Quran, and then you practice and you do
the exam. Same thing the Bible says.
There's a clear criteria of what a
Christian is. So like uh you know Shia
for example, they diverted. You know,
they don't they they would say that you
diverted. They would say that things
against Muhammad. They'll say that you
do that. We could go back to the we get
back to the Quran. Boom. And that's
exactly. So, so my problem my my thing
is this. We got to be consistent. One
thing though. Okay. Go ahead. The thing
is that uh we have one Quran. You guys
have I just showed you two different
Quran.
Uh I mean there's there's more. Trust
me. What you're saying is that like okay
look it's the clear difference, right?
It's follow the example that are in the
Quran and follow the prophets. That's
what the Bible says. There's I know, but
what I'm saying is that like all the
Qurans are going to say that. No. Okay.
So, look, here's my thing. Well, pull me
up in a Quran that says uh follow No,
no, no. The examples. I want you I want
you to be consistent. That's all I want
you to do. Okay? Cuz that's what that's
who they Well, this stuff you get in the
in the hadith, right? You you get the
the kaiffs that have come after
Muhammad, that leadership that comes
from the Hadith, not not the Quran.
Quran doesn't talk about anything like
that. Right? So without that description
of it in order for you to let me let me
say what I was going to say here cuz the
only thing I want I want is to highlight
the the double standards you're showing.
You're saying that oh the Bible has
differences so therefore um you know
it's false. I show you the Quran and you
don't have a problem with it. It's
saying that you have different you know
you have a Protestant Bible, you have a
and there's no such thing as a
Protestant Bible. Yeah, there is no
that's that's not a so-called Protestant
Bible. Just guess what? In the in the in
the Catholic Bible, they have Matthew,
Mark, Luke, and John. Just like in the
King James, one one Bible has more
books, the other one has less has more.
The Ethiopian Bible has this that you're
just talking about cannons. That's
that's not talking about different
content, but it still falls under the
religion of Christianity. But do you do
you do you know what you're talking
about here? You're okay. So when you
talk about the Catholic Bible, the the
Ethiopian Bible, what is the more books?
What what is that exactly? That's what
I'm saying. Like do you know who has the
authority to take away books? Who has to
That's not answering the question. But
that's what I'm saying. Like there's
inconsistenc inconsistency. That's not
an inconsistency. You're you're talking
about canon and you don't know what that
is talking about. Christianity, right?
Do you have all these books? So what
about so what so what about in Islam
when you have these different Qurans
with different numbers of verses
different chapters Ib Massud had a
different number of chapters than what
you have in your Quran today you have a
bunch of Muslims back in the past that
had different numbers of chapters what
do you do with that do you have
different uh
books are they 114 chapters they some
had 116 some had 112 what you have is
114 yeah that's what I follow so okay
that's what you follow. But Ibn Mass
would say that you were wrong. What do
you do? And guess what? Ib Massud is
somebody Muhammad pointed to. He said,
"You learn the Quran from him." It was
him and four and three others. Well, I
would just say this cuz my family. Yeah.
But we only follow one god. We don't do
we don't worship no human. Okay. We
don't worship a human that died on a
cross. Okay. We don't worship a human
who is allegedly God. And but you but
you have Allah who has who has human
descriptions like hands, feet, face. I'm
just saying. All right. That's that's
all I'm saying. This is what this is the
Muslim belief. I believe in a creator
who is beyond our imagination. He
created everything. Do you believe he
could come in human form if he wanted
to? No. Why would he? Why would he? Why
would he want to be a human? I'm not
saying why would he? I'm saying can he
if he wanted to. Okay. So I I know where
you're going with this question cuz then
it's like oh then God came down. I'm
just asking could he humbled himself.
Could he do it? and he sacrificed
himself. Could he do it? Why would he do
that for us? I that that's phase two.
Cuz that's a good question. Why might he
allow himself to be killed? My brother,
that's a good question. But that's phase
two. Could he do that if he wanted to in
the first place? Why would he even want
to do that? Love is the answer. Cuz he
loved us enough because we can't make
ourselves right with God. But he can do
it. If that answer works for you, that's
fine. But that's fine. But could he
could he do it? Yeah. Why would he do
that? No, you didn't work. Dude, we're
not asking why. We're not in need of
God. It's a yes or no. Could he? Could
he or not? God doesn't need us. We I
know. I Exactly. Could he do it or not?
It doesn't matter. It does. Cuz you're
saying cuz you're using this as an
example of why you reject Christianity,
but you but you but you're afraid to
acknowledge like yes, he could. You're
afraid to say yes. He could do that.
Thank you. But why? So why? So God put
himself lower than himself. He put
himself lower. Put him on a cross to
die. That to me is like, why would I
worship a God like that? Well, you will
worship a God that can demonstrate love
to you. This is what God This is what
Jesus says. Demonstrates love to me
every day that I'm alive. He doesn't.
No, he doesn't. Okay. Okay. Watch this.
I don't control my Jesus says this. He
says there's no greater love than this.
That um someone dies gives this life for
his friend. That's the greatest love
that Jesus says somebody can express. So
you serve a God who can't even express
that type of love. So human beings have
better potential and greater expression
of love than Allah does. But God of God,
the God that Jesus talks about, he's
able to come down, come in human flesh
and give his life for those he loves
because we couldn't do it. That's fine.
If that works for you, bro, that's
perfect. May God bless you with that. Uh
I would not worship a God that would
come down to earth and allow himself to
be killed by the creation that he
created. You know, but Jesus says this.
He says, "No one takes my life from me.
I lay it down of my own accord." That
you got to be able to listen to what
Jesus says. So the thing is that that is
if Jesus even said that you you don't
know what he said or didn't. Yeah. I
mean the information that we have about
Jesus is so skewed, bro. And like that I
wouldn't even What language did Jesus
speak? He didn't say that. What language
did Jesus speak? He speak uh Aramaic.
How do you know that? How do you know? I
did research. You can Google. What?
What? But what research did you do? What
tells you that? Pull it up on Google.
Yeah. You know, and what does Google
use? What's the source that Google uses
to say Jesus spoke Aramaic and Hebrew?
the collective engine sources that it
finds. But what what do those sources
use? What's what's the primary source
that tells them he spoke Hebrew and
Aramaic? The collection of whatever the
It's the Bible, brother. The Bible. So
the same So the same thing that you're
doubting is where you're getting your
information from about Jesus. Ain't that
crazy? The thing is that the first
Bible, if I'm correct, right, was
written in Greek and Jesus. No, the the
New Testament was written in Greek. Old
Testament is written in Hebrew.
Why would uh it be in in Greek if Jesus
wasn't even a Why? Why would the Quran
record Jesus's words in Arabic when
Jesus didn't speak Arabic? Uh God has
direct connection to Jesus. Exact. So
the language doesn't even matter. You
bringing up the book being written in
Greek at that time period. So then why
why does it matter? So okay, it matters.
It matters that it's it's written in
Greek and you say that Jesus never spoke
it even though you don't know that. But
he didn't speak Arabic. But yet it's his
words are recorded in the Quran. Do you
understand that? Do you see the double
standard? Do you see do do you believe
that Jesus is the daughter now? Of
course. Exactly. So he speak he can he
can speak any language he wants. Only So
So then Greek is not a problem. When he
was here, was he speaking Chinese then?
He was he was speaking Greek, Aramaic
and Hebrew. There were no ch there were
no Chinese people around. There were no
Chinese people around that time when you
not not in Rome. But would he be able to
speak Chinese? If Yeah. If he went
there, if he was talking to people who
spoke, absolutely learn how to speak
Chinese on the spot, he would able to do
it. Of course. Is there is there is
there an issue to right? And no, if he
if he could do it, he would have that
ability. Yeah, he has that ability in
himself. That's crazy, right? He he he
he created a bird from clay in the
Quran. I mean, by whose power? God
power. It doesn't say that. It says that
he created a bird from clay. I mean,
everything that every prophet has done
was just through the power of God.
their own. But it does it doesn't say
that about Jesus. It says that about all
the prophets and except except Jesus,
though. It don't say that about Jesus. I
mean, you could say whatever you want to
say, bro. But at the end of the day, I
don't worship a human being who came
down here and died. I don't I don't
worship a human being that came down
either. I worship God who has the
ability to take on human flesh and then
give his life according to his human
flesh for me. That's who I worship. God
who can do that. That's right. You can
believe in You can leave in peace. Yeah.
I appreciate you. And you can believe
what you want to believe in. Have you
ever read the gospel? I I read all of
them. You've read the gospel? I read the
gospel, but I don't believe it. I don't
believe you read the gospel, man. The
thing is that at the end of the day, uh
the the Christian belief is not for me.
You don't know that. I I do know that.
If it was true, would you believe it? Um
the thing is, bro, I used to read the
the Bible. If it was true, would you
believe it? I know it's not true. No,
I'm saying if it's not true. That's the
thing, brother. If you're if you're
saying that you're as open-minded as you
are and you appeal to truth, that would
be you ready. Look, this is your
criteria, right? You believe in Jesus
and you go to go to heaven. You believe
in Jesus, Jesus. What what does
believing in Jesus mean in Christian
paradigm? Hold on. Let me just finish a
point, right? You believe in Jesus, he
died on the cross. You're trying to tell
me what I believe, but you don't know
how to break it down. You know, you
believe all these things about Jesus.
What things? You believe that God came
down in a human form and sacrificed
himself for love. That concept to me is
like it just doesn't work in my brain.
That doesn't mean it's not true. I I can
I can say the same thing that this
religion that that that you know after
600 years um Allah allowed people to
believe that Jesus the Messiah was
crucified. Waited 600 years later to
come and say, "Hey guys, actually it was
it made it was made to look like it. It
really really wasn't him. It was made to
look like it. So 600 years Allah allowed
this to build up and create Christianity
and a whole bunch of millions of people
are going to go to hell because they
believe in the crucifixion. That doesn't
make sense to me. Not really. It's out
of their control whether it is God is
all merciles. So if someone lied to you
about something and you didn't know you
were being lied to, but Allah is the one
who did that. Allah's the one who
everyone has uh look if God comes in and
intervenes in your life then this test
of life is void. What if he intervenes
with the deception? taking a test and
the teacher comes in. Oh, hey, you know
what? You have the answer test. You have
you have these answers wrong. Switch it
up. What if what if he intervenes with
the deception? He makes you believe
something that's not true and then
punishes you for for believing that. So,
you know what Allah means? You know what
the translation for that is? What What
does that have to do with the question I
just asked? Because you're saying God,
bro. Yes. No, I'm saying Allah the
Allah. So, the God of the Quran
specifically, the God of Islam. Got it.
What if he intervenes with a deception
and then punishes you for believing the
deception he gave you in the first
place? You don't know that. What do you
mean I don't know that? You don't know
that. The Quran says that they neither
It says they neither killed him nor
crucified him, but it was made to
appear. So
who made who made it appear that Jesus
was crucified? So here's the thing. The
obviously the people who wanted to
crucify him, they wanted him dead,
right? So they won't make it look like
he did it. They'll do it. They they
thought that they did it. That's fine.
They can believe that. So who who made
it look like they did it? So the the
concept is that God saved Jesus from
being I know who made it look like he
was crucified cuz it says it was made to
appear so it looked like he was who made
understand the difference
of so that's the scenario right they're
trying to crucify him. Yeah. God saved
Jesus so he appears that he was
crucified. So Allah made it look like
Jesus was crucified when instead he
saved Right. Okay. Good. So not so not
only he did he trick the people who
tried to kill Jesus but he also tricked
the people who believed in Jesus cuz
they all thought he was crucified and
then went around spreading hey Jesus was
crucified and then when they saw Jesus
again they thought he rose from the dead
and so Allah let this build up and
spread for 600 years. When did it say
that Jesus came back in the front? So so
that doesn't say that. Okay. So then but
this is what we have in history.
Exactly. But what we
have the line No, you're missing it.
What we have in history because the
Quran never says Jes Okay then. So where
did it come from that Jesus was risen
again? Where did that come from? Cuz
that was a saying before the before
Quran. Exactly. The book the the Holy
Bible is filled with lies. Oh, so you're
saying it's filled with lies. Yet
according to what the Quran is showing,
Allah gave you gave us a lie to believe
he was crucified. So this idea that
Jesus was crucified came from Allah. He
saved Jesus. How is that? By making us
think that he was crucified, right? I
mean, he saved Jesus. That's the point.
He saved Jesus. Those people wanted to
kill by making it look like he was
crucified,
right? You understand he was saved? I
understand that. Look, look, I'm going
to break it down. Allah saved Jesus. So,
by making it look like he was crucified,
right? Those evil people, they wanted
you. Not just the evil people, the
people, the his mother, the his
believers, they all thought he was
crucified because Allah made it look
like it was. So then Allah gave this
trick to not just disbelievers, but he
tricked believers as well. So these
believers who are innocent are tricked
by Allah thinking he was crucified,
believe he was crucified, and Allah
waits 600 years later to clear the air.
That's right. How does that make sense?
Look, if you were lied to about that,
you were lied to about that by Allah.
Allah is the one who lied about it. Bro,
those people have been lying about
not the believers. Why did Jesus come
down? So, this will clear this up. Why
did he come down? The Jews at that time
were already spreading corruption.
You're right. This this is this is why
Jesus came down. He says it in Mark
10:45. He says, "For this reason I came
to not be serve, not to serve, but to
I'm sorry, not to be served, but to
serve and to give my life as a ransom
for many." So, he literally said, "And
this mission is to come to give his
life." Allegedly. No, that's what he
says. Really, bro? That's you know the
And then you have to consider which
Bible says that. All of them, every last
one, everything in Mark, Mark 10:45, any
book of Mark that you pick up, verse
10:45 says the same thing. There's no
difference any anywhere. At the end of
the day, bro, you could worship uh
worship your God who died on the cross.
I'm going to worship my God and rose
again in authority. He's not all
powerful. He He has to lie to save Jesus
and then and then he can't have a son
without a lie about saving. He saved
him. You're saying if he lied about
saving Jesus, that would have mean that
Jesus died. Yeah, he did die. He did
die. So the Quran says that they neither
killed him nor crucify him, but it was
made to appear so. So the lie is that he
made it look like Jesus was crucified
when he wasn't. So that's the lie. It's
not a lie. How is it not a lie? Because
he's he's saving Jesus. Is it deceitful?
Huh? Is it deceitful? It's not
deceitful. How? Bro, so to deceive is to
bring something that's false. Let's say
you're on the cross and I'm going to uh
do my best to save you. Y and I found
someone who looks just exactly like you.
Yeah. So, somebody else gets somebody
else gets punished and killed for Jesus.
It could be someone who deserves it.
Someone who's trying to put you in under
the boat. The Quran doesn't say none of
that. Yeah. We believe that the person
who is uh was replaced with Jesus, the
one that was actually crucified was the
one who was uh uh wanting to harm Jesus,
which is who threw him under the bus. We
don't know who, but you don't know who.
So, where do you where do you get this
from that that it was somebody that
threw Jesus under the bus that was
crucified in this place? Where do you
get that from? The Quran don't say that.
I heard it from somewhere.
That's what we believe. You know, some
people say Judas. That don't make no
sense. So, where do you get this Judas
name from? Where do you get that from?
That's where we believe it may have been
Judas. But where do they get this from?
Uh, I would have to bring up my source.
But no, what I'm saying is the people
who come up with this this story, this
conjecture that Judas replaced Jesus,
where do they even get this idea of a
Judas character? That's a good point.
You know the answer to that. What? The
Bible.
Yeah, we're going to keep on. All right.
Take care. Yes, sir. Yes, sir.
Uh we are going to be brothers when the
time that uh you know Jesus comes back
and clears everything up. Read the
gospel man. Just read it again. Coming.
So don't worry bro. Try it again. Try
the gospel again. Just try it again. I
can't. You can. No bro. I already
explained it to you. A man who died on
the cross who was allegedly God. Like I
don't believe that. I think that you
have a biased against it and you're not
willing to deal with it. Worship someone
who died on a cross. It's like
worshiping somebody. Worship somebody
who worship somebody who deceives
mankind and also worship someone who
can't have a son without a mate. This is
the god you're serving. The thing is
that
uh there's no that's the difference. We
believe in an almighty God. No. No, you
don't. He doesn't need anything. So then
why did he have to lie to save Jesus?
Everything needs Why did he have to lie
to save Jesus? You don't understand,
bro. I know I don't. That's what I'm
asking. I don't understand it. He didn't
lie about saving Jesus. He lied to save.
He saved Jesus. Okay. You know what I
mean? Yeah. But at the end of the day,
bro, we're all brothers. We're all
human. Uh I'm confident on the day of
judgment, you know, and it's coming.
None of us can avoid death. And we're
all going to uh learn the truth at the
end of the day. So, uh if I'm wrong, I'm
going to find out that you judge me. If
you're wrong, you're going to already
know.
Oh my god. Logic.
[Music]
Yeah. Heat.